hey guys what's up now this is another
video request because there has been a
lot of you guys that asked me hey Daniel
how can I make my eyes look more
attractive so in this video I'm gonna
give you ten tips to make your eyes look
a lot better and if you watch the video
until the end I'll give you a bonus tip
as well so let's not waste any more time
let's get into the video
[Music]
now just in case you're new here to my
channel please subscribe and click the
notification ballot so you won't miss
any of my next videos and welcome to d
LM model lifestyle now whether you're
going for a job interview or for your
first date your eyes play a very
important role why because the eyes are
the part of your body that people
connect with you mostly even if you
don't talk a lot your eyes speak a great
deal they're kind of like the window to
the soul right you've probably heard
that before now how do you make your
eyes look more attractive well their
eyes consist out of four parts first of
all you've got your eyeball right then
you've got your eyebrows you've got your
eyelashes and you've got the skin around
your eyes so to have more attractive
eyes you need to improve these four
parts and I'm gonna tell you exactly how
to do it so let's start with the first
step
[Music]
all right you can use certain I
solutions to clear up the redness in
your eyes and to make your eyeballs look
whiter
for example eyedrops can be used to help
the redness from not sleeping enough for
even allergies now if you're not sure
which kind of eyedrops to use I'll add
my preferred eyedrops in the video
description down below now try not to do
alcohol and drugs as well because they
also cause the redness in your eyes just
like your body your eyes also need good
rest right so give it the amount of
sleep that it needs if you don't sleep
enough it can cause popped blood vessels
dark eyes puffy eyes dry eyes and even
eye spasms so try to get a good sleeping
the routine where you sleep between 7
and 8 hours per day that should be
enough
now you can also use the right household
items to improve your eyes for example
thinly-sliced cold cucumbers or even
granny smith apples will help you to
reduce the puffiness under your eyes and
then slices of potato can help you to
reduce those dark circles around your
eyes
another example is caffeinated tea bags
now what you can do is just soak two tea
bags in warm water and then just chill
them for a few minutes in the
refrigerator then what you do is you
just put them on your eyes for a few
minutes why well the caffeine helps to
string the blood vessels around your
eyes which reduces puffiness and dark
circles
all right now you got to use the right
kind of aij Elle's and eye creams to
improve this area of skin around your
eyes if the skin around your eyes is
mostly kind of dry that's probably
because it has very few active oil
glands so it doesn't really have a
natural ability to keep your skin kind
of moist and glowy now if you're not
sure which products to use I'll add a
few of my top picks in a video
description below so you can check it
out now let's move on to the next step
all right now you probably know this
already but you have to drink enough
water
why well if you don't drink enough water
your eyes will become more dehydrated
and look kinda dull so drink more water
so that your eyes can look nice and
fresh
now let's talk about the eyebrows now
not everybody needs to do this but if
your eyebrows are kind of all over the
place right and they're very bushy like
especially if they're here in the middle
you gotta keep them in shape but never
wax your eyebrows just use tweezers
because if you do wax your eyebrows
those lines is gonna be too abrupt and
kind of artificial and you don't want it
to look that sharp you just want it to
look nice and natural so just take a
tweezer you know and what I usually do
sometimes if it's a problem as I just
tweeze these bottom hair here all right
because you want your eyebrows to be a
little bit upper you know if it's down
too close to your eyes people can't see
it that well all right
the other tip for the eyebrows is
sometimes when you wake up your eyebrows
will be down here so what you want to do
is just take them a little bit up you
don't have to take a brush and brush
them unless you have those gonna
eyebrows that you really need a brush
but just do this all right and then boom
that's fine
alright now let's talk about those
wrinkles I've got to start here in your
eyes and they kind of fan out there
called crow's feet now what can you do
to prevent crow's feet well before I
tell you let me just say I like crow's
feet I won't mind as I grow older to
have crow's feet because I think it kind
of looks cool it gives a kind of
character but I know there's not a lot
of people that like it so what can you
do about it to be honest there are no
products that can get rid of crow's feet
even if a company tells you they can
don't believe them so what can you do
well apart from using sunscreen what you
can do is use products that are loaded
with superior anti-wrinkle ingredients
for example antioxidants skin
replenishing ingredients and skin
restoring ingredients now although these
products will help you to kind of slow
down the wrinkles and make the skin
around your eyes look a lot better it is
definitely not gonna get rid of crow's
feet but it is gonna let it look and
appear a lot better check out the video
description if you're not sure which
products to use and you can check out my
best options
now let's talk about eye lashes now what
can you do to improve your eye lashes
well most people want the longer
eyelashes because it is well known that
it gets a little bit longer it makes
your eyes look a little bit more
attractive so what I usually do is when
I wake up these eyelashes are usually
bended and kind of skewing all over the
place so what I would do after I wash my
face is I would take some lukewarm water
just rub it here my fingers and then I
would take these eyelashes and just
straighten them you know and then when
it dries it is more straight and so it
looks longer now you can even go further
than that if you really want to you can
use the eye lash curler now I'll notice
a lot of guys gonna be like oh man
that's for girls and that's fine I don't
usually use it but if I have a very
important casting for a high wear
company or something like that then yes
I would because it does make a huge
difference it makes your eyes pop a lot
more but it's also understandable if you
don't want to do it because that is your
choice ultimately and so I'm just giving
you all the options out there right so
you can choose so please don't judge me
in the comments below I'm just giving
you all the options out there for a
better video now you can even go a lot
further than just the eye color and that
takes us to the next tip now if you were
born with short eyelashes and you want
longer eyelashes the good news is you
can do something about it you can use
eye serums to make your eyelashes grow
longer but just be careful about the
products that you choose because there's
a lot of products out there that is not
backed up by a good evidence now
personally I have not used any of these
I serums but I did do a lot of research
especially for you guys if there is some
of you that would like to use it and
I'll add my best top picks in the video
description down below so you can check
it out and do your own research
all right you gotta eat healthier if you
don't eat healthier eyes they're gonna
show it they're gonna look on a dull so
if you want bright healthy eyes you need
to get more antioxidants more healthy
fats like omega-3 fatty acids and then
also certain vitamins like vitamin A now
I'm not gonna go into a lot of detail
but here's a few foods that can really
improve your eyes salmon egg yolk sweet
potatoes spinach blueberries carrots
peppers avocados and nuts all right guys
you made it until the end of the video
so here's my bonus tip you gotta wear
sunglasses when you're outside yes you
do it probably every day when you go
outside and when the Sun is sharp and
it's a little bit bright you squint
right so you walk like this and then if
you do today tomorrow a week month years
you start to get a lot more wrinkles but
when you wear the glasses sunglasses
then you don't need to squint so much
right and also if you do wear it it
already protects you against the Sun
which means it protects you against
wrinkles now if you're not sure which
kind of sunglasses will fit in with your
face shape the general rule is this you
gotta buy sunglasses with a shape that
is the opposite shape of your face shape
well there's a lot of shapes and that's
intense but you get what I'm saying
right if not let me explain it an
example if you have a round face it is
generally better to buy sunglasses that
is square shape or rectangular shape all
right I'll add my few best options of
sunglasses in a video description so you
can check that out as well and that's it
guys thank you so much for watching
click the like button and subscribe
button and then don't miss the next
video that's it
Cheers
you